pvd you brought up the fact that trump
had some favorable words to say about
putin i believe that was two days ago
this was prior to the to the attack
uh i would hope that maybe his tune has
changed since the attack
you brought up the fact that maybe biden
and trump do a joint press conference or
i know you've been obviously working on
getting
obama and trump to do some sort of sit
down together
obviously you know you're thinking
positive of what would be best for
america if you can put yourself into
trump shoes right now what do you think
trump
should do to help unify america over
this situation in russia because
obviously he has not said anything bad
about putin publicly possibly ever
is this a time for him to speak out what
would you do if uh if you were trump
right about now
well you have to realize he doesn't
believe in the current head coach
he doesn't believe in the current
commander-in-chief he has zero respect
for the guy but he believes in america
i i i'm not you heard what i just said i
think they need to do i just gave you my
proposal what they need to do it would
be great for america to show strength
of us doing that but we're not there
right now i mean i i i already talked
about what trump would do if it was him
but trump may also look at this
opportunity to say many of the american
people may sit there and say look
i i didn't like you trump and i still
don't like you but i prefer you as a
president over biden if you think how
trump thinks
trump still walks around in mar-a-lago
and everywhere he goes as if he's the
current president
i i i you have to think how he thinks
he still thinks he's the president he's
he keeps saying your president what does
that mean his emails end with your
president your president he
in his mind there's a 90 chance he's
going to be the president two years
three years and he's going to see he's
going to let this thing to get so ugly
in america for him to come and say you
miss me yet and then that's how his
legacy is going to end
in his early 80s and then he's going to
go and do whatever he wants to do for
the rest of his life
and history will say they impeached him
twice but he came back and he saved
america from world war cold war about
that's kind of how he sees themselves so
he doesn't see himself as a person
that's going to call biden and say let
me give you some feedback he doesn't
seem to but do you think he should call
out putin at this point
look okay so go back to brexit do you
remember brexit of course you guys
remember brexit
a lot of people weren't for brexit
do you remember how big of a topic it
was
but trump was okay with brexit
he was kind of okay with it do you guys
remember what position he had for he was
okay with brexit
a lot of people and you weren't okay for
brexit
a lot of different people weren't okay
for brexit what do you mean we let them
out
and and he would say well all these
other countries that are in there
they're not paying their fair share
why are they in it
why they're not paying their fair share
so there was an element of admiration he
had for putin
to not rely on nato and stand on his own
because it's kind of like i don't need
you i can do it on my own because that's
kind of what he did i don't need my dad
i can stand on my own i can go out there
and make it in manhattan and i'm going
to make it my dad made it in jersey but
i'm going to make it in manhattan so he
admires people like that
who don't want to get into the help of
all these other people and you know he
admires that he admires men like that he
doesn't see putin as
you know a country that he's sitting
there saying at least i don't think
uh he's trump is america first one
million percent but he probably looks at
putin as a strategist saying he's
exploiting biden right now after seeing
how taliban exploited biden with
afghanistan and now china's trying to
exploit biden with taiwan putin's trying
to exploit biden with ukraine if he can
get it why not putin is probably sitting
there saying wait a minute the taliban
got afghanistan why can't i get ukraine
this is my time you don't think those
types of conversations took place i
think a big part of how
biden handled afghanistan is what led to
putin attacking and wanting to get
ukraine back i may be wrong but that's
what i believe
[Music]
you